Today’s video is sponsored by
Keeps, more on that in a moment.
With
nearly 10 million inhabitants and some
200,000 km² or some 77,000 square miles,
today's protagonist is a country that has
recently stood out for three main reasons:
First, for being considered, no less
than the last dictatorship in Europe.
Second, for having played and continuing to play
a key role in the Russian invasion of Ukraine.
And third, in exactly the same vein,
for being the only European ally left
to Vladimir Putin's Russia.
Of course, we are talking
about Alexander Lukashenko's Belarus.
Never before had this country played
such a prominent role. Remember that this was the
country where the Wagner's agreed to take refuge
after mutinying and marching on Moscow.
And, it is also the place where the very
invasion of Ukraine began on 24 February 2022.
Don’t forget that the first Russian offensive
started from the Belarusian region of Homiel. And
that was not all, at the same time, in parallel
with the advance of ground troops, the Russian
air force launched dozens of attacks against
Ukrainian targets with aircraft and missiles that
took off and were also launched from Belarus.
Despite Lukashenko's historic promises that
Ukraine would never be attacked from his
country, in the Russian plans to take over Kyiv in
72 hours, Belarus played an absolutely key role.
("Those who reproach us, didn't you know that
we have the closest alliance with the Russian
Federation? With them we are building a single,
powerful, independent state – the Union State.
We have been and will be together with fraternal
Russia. Our participation in the 'special
operation' was decided by me a long time ago"
– Alexander Lukashenko, President of Belarus)
Since then, this has been by far the country
most affected by international sanctions,
both economically and politically. Some
of the country's best known companies have
even decided to leave the country. Take
Wargaming, for example, the developer of
well-known games such as this one:
(Belarus' biggest games company is
leaving the country – and Russia. World of Tanks
developer Wargaming to close studios and transfer
operation of games – Polygon)
But do you know what,
none of this is even the worst of it.
The worst thing is that a long time
after the war started, it is no longer
Ukraine's sovereignty that is at risk,
but that of Belarus itself.
Yes, yes, that’s right:
This country could disappear in the not
too distant future, and not precisely by
being invaded by Ukraine or NATO. Belarus runs the
risk of being annexed by the great Russian bear.
Without going any further, the Ukrainian
Parliament itself considers that Russia
has de facto already occupied it. This
is practically the same position held
by the Belarusian opposition in exile.
And this has caused us at VisualPolitik
to ask a few questions:
To what extent is Belarus at
risk of being annexed by Russia? What is behind
Moscow's alleged intentions? Why does Lukashenko
seem to be doing nothing about it?
Well, in this video we will answer
these and other questions.
But before we get started…
Believe it or not, hair loss is a problem that
affects over 60% of men. While there isn’t a
magic cure for baldness, it's possible
to prevent hair loss from worsening.
Keeps offers an online subscription
service, allowing you to customize
an FDA-approved solution based on
your specific stage of hair loss.
Once your treatment plan is in
place, your products are discreetly
shipped in non-branded packaging. Choose
shipment intervals of every three, six,
or twelve months, based on what suits you best.
Unfortunately it’s a bit late for
me – Keeps can only stop hair loss,
not regenerate hair so it’s best to take
action in the early stages of hair loss.
Most Keeps users observe noticeable
results within six months of starting
their treatment. But don’t just take our word
for it, head to their website and check the
reviews for before and after photos of real
men who have had success with this program.
So if this is a problem that is bothering you or
someone you care about and you have a US address,
remember: Hair loss stops with Keeps.
For a special offer to get started, go to
keeps.com/VISUALPOLITIK or click the link in the
description. That’s K-E-E-P-S
dot com slash VISUALPOLITIK
And now, let's get started.
Basically, VisualPolitik viewers,
Belarus has one major problem:
From Moscow's perspective, this is not really
a foreign country nor a fully independent one.
Instead, they see it as a kind
of autonomous territory that
somehow really belongs to Mother Russia itself.
And, of course, as you can imagine knowing all
the background, this is extremely disturbing.
But the worst thing is that this is not
an exclusively Russian perspective.
When Lukashenko came to power in 1994 he
did so by winning an election in which his
campaign was based above all on integration with
Russia... Particularly in the economic sphere,
but not only there. Let's say that, at the
time, Lukashenko received political and
economic support from Moscow in exchange
for reinforcing the Russian worldview.
In fact, the Belarusian identity, which for years
has been promoted and continues to be promoted by
the regime, is based above all on the cult of the
Soviet past, on the "Great Patriotic War" – the
Second World War – and brotherhood with Russia.
About the rest of Belarus' past... Not a whisper.
Lukashenko himself has even said on
state television that Belarusians,
in essence, are "Russians with a
quality seal". Yes, I kid you not.
In fact, it was to a large extent this position
that explains why in 1999 Moscow and Minsk signed
a bilateral treaty to progressively
constitute the so-called Union State.
In other words, the two countries decided
to merge. Well, not to merge exactly, but to
strengthen to the extreme their social, political
and economic integration with joint institutions:
We are talking, for example, about a
common currency and a unified tax code.
For now, it has not gone that far, but from
the very beginning, freedom of movement between
the two countries and the unification of
the two labor markets were established.
And so, Russians and Belarusians do not
need permits or any other particular
documents to work in either country.
But... All in all, the question
we have to ask is, why did Belarus
decide to take this important step?
Let's see, apparently, it had everything to lose,
right? A small country associating with a much
larger one... It is clear that Moscow would
end up making all the decisions, isn't it?
Well, actually, no. Or at least that's not
what Lukashenko thought.... Check it out.
The 1990s were very hard for Russia, the country
was in a constant crisis and this awakened the
ambition of the Belarusian leader. As we have
already told you on several occasions, Lukashenko
came to think that in many joint bodies the weight
of power of Russia and Belarus would be exactly
the same. He even went so far as to think that
he himself could lead this kind of supra-state.
Obviously, the passage of time made
things begin to look completely different,
to the point that these days we are not
talking about a partnership for Belarus but
about the real risk of annexation to Russia.
And the question is, was Lukashenko so naïve?
How could Europe's last dictator
be a guy who is so easily played?
Well, the truth is that this is not quite
the case. The Belarusian dictator always
had one eye on Russia and one eye on the
West... Until one day all that changed.
So what happened to make Minsk practically
surrender to Moscow? Well, let's take a look.
(THE CALCULATED AMBIGUITY)
Shortly after the signing of
the State of the Union Treaty, the commodity and
oil super-cycle began, which consolidated Putin's
first period at the helm of Russia.
During those years dollars started
flowing into Russia like there was
no tomorrow and, of course, Belarus
benefited from that sudden wave of prosperity:
Its exports to the Russian giant skyrocketed,
many young people moved to the neighboring country
to work and, naturally, direct investment by
Russian companies in the country multiplied. These
were the golden years of Lukashenko's Belarus.
But, as the saying goes, all that glittered was
not gold. There was a problem, a big problem that
kept the Belarusian dictator awake at night.
Soon after Putin came to power, Lukashenko
understood perfectly well that the new Russian
leader was not like Yeltsin and that, therefore,
his plans to pilot the joint State they had
agreed to create were doomed to absolute failure.
As a result they started dragging their feet on
the project in Minsk. And not only that, when oil
prices deflated, the Belarusian government took
the opportunity to stop looking directly to Moscow
and to start paying more attention to the West.
The target was the giant European Union market.
And that's not even all, it also began to
cultivate a national identity of its own,
one that went beyond Russia.
For example, in 2014 several
Russian media outlets began to blame
the Belarusian leader for flirting
with nationalism and trying
to supplant Russian culture.
("There is an undeclared Russophobic campaign in
Belarus and nationalist forces are being openly
pandered to. – Pro-Russian political
commentator Yuriy Baranchik in 2014)
The government slyly took all sorts of
measures, some as symbolic as replacing
St. George ribbons – which are widely used
at celebrations – with green-red ribbons
imitating the colors of the official flag.
Also, in 2018, the regime went so far as to
allow – and some say even encourage – public
celebrations for the 100th anniversary of
the Belarusian republic that was declared in
1918 after temporarily seceding from Russia.
This had been the first attempt at national
independence in its modern history. As you can
imagine, it’s a symbol for nationalist movements.
But these are just two examples of a movement
that clearly sought to reinforce a true
national identity for the first time.
Not surprisingly, by that time the Belarusian
regime had already become much more cautious
about Putin's new Russia. They did not trust
it, they knew that if they did not consolidate
a clear national identity and start looking
for commercial and economic alternatives,
the country would sooner or later be swallowed
up by Russia. They were even willing to give up
certain subsidies in exchange for more
economic and political independence.
At that time, beyond appearances, the
truth is that relations between Minsk
and Moscow were not exactly the best.
In fact, in early 2020 Russia went so
far as to cut off oil supplies to
this country and re-established
border controls on the movement of people.
To give you an idea of how things stood,
Lukashenko refused at all times to
recognize the Russian annexation of
Crimea. For him, Crimea was still Ukraine.
And he also made statements like this:
(Belarus would never allow other countries to
use our territory for military intervention in
Ukraine – Alexander Lukashenko, 2017)
The problem is that looking to the
West is sometimes easier said than done,
especially if you are a dictatorship with
an iron fist and a terribly obsolete economy.
In the case of Belarus, all that it could export
to the European Union were basically commodities
and low value-added products: wood, metal,
potatoes and, above all, petrochemical products.
You see, Belarus has a huge installed capacity
to produce fuels and oil derivatives. So
what’s the problem? That the whole industry,
the largest in the country, basically depends
on the supply of cheap Russian oil. And so,
while it increased its exports to the West,
it increased its dependence on Russia.
It was not an easy situation, but in
any case the truth was that the distance
between Moscow and Minsk was increasing.
You could say it was the great opportunity
to take Belarus out of the Kremlin's sphere
of control once and for all. Nevertheless,
VisualPolitik viewers, in 2020 this
whole process suddenly fell apart.
And no, it was not because of what you
are thinking, the crucial event in this
whole story was not Covid-19, but the
presidential elections. Check it out.
On 9 August 2020 presidential
elections were held. Lukashenko's
candidacy officially won just over 80%
of the vote. Of course, these elections
were almost as rigged as a track and field
race involving King-Jong-un in North Korea.
And the result sparked huge peaceful protests
demanding a game change in the country. The
protests were so large and had so much
international support that for the first
time the Belarusian regime was on the ropes.
And that's not even all, to make matters worse,
the Belarusians began to withdraw money en
masse from the banks and tried by all means
to convert their local rubles into stronger
currencies, such as the dollar or the euro,
in case anything should happen. Within a month
the Belarusians practically exhausted the
reserves of the central bank and institutions
such as the IMF refused to come to their aid.
The country was on the verge of collapse
and Lukashenko's dictatorship seemed to be
hanging by a thread. There was only one way
out: to throw himself into Russia's arms.
And guess what? No sooner said than
done. That's exactly what he did.
The Belarusian regime asked
Vladimir Putin for help,
and within days Russia approved
a first bailout of $1.5 billion.
Then, along with that financial bailout,
Russia also promised military assistance....
(16 August, 2020: Vladimir Putin
has offered to send military
assistance to support Belarus President
Alexander Lukashenko as up to 200,000
protesters gather to demand
his removal – Business Insider)
On top of that the Kremlin also sent all kinds
of propaganda and repression professionals.
Without going any further, the television
channels were practically taken over by
Russian propagandists. Propagandists who were
naturally under orders from Moscow, not Minsk.
Be that as it may, the point is that with
all this help and with the guarantee that
the Russian army would prevent any kind of
uprising against the Belarusian government,
Lukashenko was able to increase the repression
and persecution of all political opposition
without fearing the consequences.
In 2021, this even happened, remember?
(23 May 2021: Ryanair confirms that Belarus has
forced one of its planes to land – EuropaPress)
Exactly, the Belarusian air force forced
a Ryanair plane flying between Athens and
Vilnius to land in Minsk in order
to arrest Roman Protasevich and his
partner Sofia Sapega. Protasevich is
a journalist and critical opposition
activist with asylum in the European Union.
[Wait a minute, to force a European commercial
airliner to land between two European cities,
even sending a fighter jet to make it happen,
and all that to detain a person with political
asylum in Europe? Obviously, that meant crossing
all red lines, but at that time in Minsk, thanks
to Moscow's support, they could afford to do it.
There was only one problem: gifts are almost never
free. And they certainly weren't in this case.
In return for all this help, the
Belarusian dictator had to grant
the Kremlin far more influence than ever before.
He even had to commit himself to pushing through
a constitutional reform that would, for
example, allow the permanent deployment
of Russian troops in the country. Crazy!
As you can imagine, this whole process was
accompanied by a lot of new sanctions from the
international community, which obviously further
deepened the country’s dependence on Russia.
Let's just say that the era of looking
to the West had come to an end for good.
And it was at this point that everything changed.
For years, Belarus had strongly opposed
the opening of Russian military bases
in the country. They understood, logically,
that this posed an intolerable threat. After
the "rescue" of 2020, however, there was no
choice but to give in to Russian demands.
For example, in addition to growing military ties,
from 2020 onwards, strong anti-Western rhetoric
was also launched by the Belarusian government,
the State of the Union returned to the front page,
in 2021, tens of thousands of migrants from
the Middle East and Africa were used to cause
a political and humanitarian crisis on
the border with Poland and Lithuania,
and in November of the same year, Minsk recognized
Crimea as part of Russia for the first time.
What’s more, an intensive Russification program
was also launched in the country. Even sculptures
of the rulers of the Grand Duchy of Lithuania
were removed from the National Museum. From
that point on, the past of Belarus could only
– at least "officially" – pass through Russia.
However, it is not only political
factors, the ties with the rest
of the world and cultural-identity issues
that endanger the independence of Belarus.
The truth is that this country is more
and more intertwined with Russia. In fact,
it is difficult, very difficult, to say
that it is still an independent country.
But, do you want to know exactly what we
are talking about? Well... listen up.
(A HOSTILE TAKEOVER BID)
VisualPolitik community, the Russian invasion of
Ukraine made Belarus a pariah State and completely
marginalized it on the international markets.
The international community applied practically
the same sanctions as it did to Russia... With
one big difference: this country has no oil,
gas or nuclear technology to play with
on the global geopolitical chessboard.
In fact, Belarus has nothing to play with
and that explains why sanctions here have
been much more devastating than in Russia itself.
For example, in the first months of the war alone,
Belarusian exports to the European Union
plummeted by almost 60%, some of the most
thriving companies left the country, industry had
to lay off more than 15% of its workers, wages in
the sanction sectors plummeted and the economy
as a whole fell by an optimistic 5% in 2022.
And, of course, as we have already told you, all
this has made Belarus today much more dependent
on motherland Russia than ever before.
But... Now, the question we have to ask is,
how far does all this dependence really go?
Well, the truth is that it is almost total.
It is so extensive that one of the country's
major sources of public revenue consists of
reselling on the international market part of the
oil it receives at subsidized prices from Russia.
According to estimates, we are talking
about a profit in 2022 of $1.7 billion
dollars from this operation alone. In 2023 it
is expected to be almost $3 billion dollars.
Obviously, in Russia they know about this
operation, and guess what? Ultimately they
don't care. They are the ones in control of the
crude oil tap. In fact, one of the country's
main exports is fuels... Produced from Russian
oil, something that for years was encouraged by
Moscow. What better way to control a country if
its main industry depends exclusively on you?
And it's not even just the oil it resells or the
fuel it exports. In total, more than two-thirds of
the energy the country consumes either comes from
Russia or is controlled by Russian companies.
In other words, in the current context,
if Moscow were to turn off the tap,
Belarus would practically go dark.
But, let's look beyond energy.
About half of all the country's public debt is in
Russian hands; then with foreign direct investment
it is a very similar story and to top it off
many Russian state-owned companies control key
assets in Belarus: we are talking about banks,
telecommunications companies and refineries.
Even worse, it is estimated that today,
60-70% of all Belarusian exports go
to the land of Vladimir Putin.
In other words, from an economic
point of view, we can no longer speak
of a completely independent country.
All this explains why, when Russia wanted to
invade Ukraine and take Kyiv in three days,
it used this country. Lukashenko could not
oppose it. In fact, since the beginning of
the invasion of Ukraine, this country has been
one of the main bases for missile launches,
has given the Russian armed forces a
substantial part of its military arsenals,
has allowed them intensive use
of its railroads and roads,
and has even become a key medical center for
soldiers fallen or wounded at the front.
But... Wait a minute, this is nothing new,
so why do we say that there is now a
real risk of annexation by Russia?
Well because Belarus may end up
becoming a kind of consolation prize.
Think about it, however the Ukrainian war ends,
it is clear that this campaign has been and will
be a resounding failure. And, obviously, no
tyrant likes to present himself as defeated.
Putin promised to protect Russia
and make it bigger... But that
is no longer happening in Ukraine.
For years Belarus tried to juggle:
to take advantage of the Russian bear without
falling completely into its clutches. Now that
no longer seems possible. Putin knows this and
seems more than willing to take advantage of
this situation. One way would be to force an
annexation to Russia under the framework of
the Union State or some other political
invention, such as the recreation of the
satellite states of the former Soviet Union.
In this way he could sell the picture of a
bigger and stronger Russia. A success in
the framework of a tremendous political,
economic and military defeat. From the Kremlin's
point of view, not a bad move, don't you think?
VisualPolitik community, all indications are that
Belarus in one way or another may be on the verge
of losing its sovereignty, if it has not already
lost it. The attempt to harbor the Wagners was
perhaps Lukashenko's last attempt to secure more
room for maneuver, but with the fall of Prigozhin,
that is now history.
As it stands, Belarus
is likely to disappear from
the map. Be that as it may,
and given that we do not have a crystal ball,
the best thing we can do is to open the debate:
Do you think that Russia will definitely
annex Belarus, will it turn it into a
completely subordinate state or, on the
contrary, will Lukashenko and the rest of
Minsk's managers be able to keep their heads?
What should the West do about this whole saga?
Leave us your thoughts in the comments. And,
of course, if you found this video interesting,
don't forget to like and subscribe to
VisualPolitik if you haven't already done so.
Thank you very much for watching.
All the best and see you next time.